what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder i'm your host
warren thompson and marvel has
officially revealed phase five and some
of phase six now it's probably pretty
doubtful if you're here that you missed
the reveal of phase five but in case you
did miss it marvel added three new
projects an 18 episode long daredevil
born again disney plush show a new
captain america show captain america new
world order and to close off phase five
we have the thunderbolts however kevin
feige gave us a sneak peek into phase
six he told us that phase six is going
to end with avengers secret wars we're
also going to be getting avengers the
king dynasty before then and we are
going to be getting the fantastic four
on november 8th of 2024 however there
are eight slots in phase six that have
not been revealed yet and of course fans
want to know well what the heck are they
and although these were some pretty
great reveals fans were kind of
expecting some x-men or mutant news and
possible news about deadpool 3 but don't
worry that's what we're about to talk
about here all of the projects that we
know about that are going to take these
slots in phase six so let's dive into it
and of course if you love the mcu be
sure to subscribe so you don't miss out
on any of the latest videos so let's
first talk about the x-men because a lot
of people were really expecting some
mutant news but keep in mind these
missing projects for phase six are most
likely going to be revealed in only a
couple of months from now at disney's
d23 event marvel has an insanely huge
panel there so you know they had to save
some stuff for that and what's crazy and
kind of makes you think is that they
actually revealed so much at san diego
comic con all of phase 5 including those
new projects and huge projects of phase
six two avengers films and the date for
the fantastic four it makes you wonder
what do they have left and how exciting
is it going to be you'd have to imagine
it's pretty dang exciting if they chose
to leave it out of san diego comic-con
and keep it for the big surprise at d23
so let's talk about the mutants first
because that is clearly something that
was held back for d23 now there are two
different ways that they could go with
the x-men since they announced secret
wars which is where universes start to
collide into each other otherwise known
as an incursion which is what dr strange
and the multiverse of madness explained
to us this is clearly going to happen in
secret wars and the x-men can either
come before or after it all depends on
what their origin is going to be inside
of the mcu if the mutants are going to
be from another universe that means they
probably come after during or right
before secret wars because it will be
the events of secret wars that bring the
mutants from another universe into ours
that could happen however i do think
they're going to come before secret wars
i think they're going to start to come
in phase six probably early on the last
thing that kevin feige talked about at
san diego comic con in 2019 was the
mutants and he talked about them when
talking about the fantastic four so
clearly the plans for the fantastic four
of the mutants are somewhat close to
each other time wise on the phase six
slate so i'm assuming the x-men movie
slash mutants movie because we're not
sure what they'll call it or if the
x-men team already exists in the mcu
will probably come early on in phase six
then of course we have deadpool 3.
deadpool 3 is 100 coming in phase 6. a
lot of the cast has already been
assembled for deadpool 3 as we speak
they have a couple of head writers of
course ryan reynolds is helping write
the movie as well ryan reynolds has met
with marvel studios plenty of times
because he's posted pictures of him at
marvel studios and recently disney plus
has added logan deadpool 1 and deadpool
2 to disney plus still rated r so they
are preparing for deadpool 3 to enter
the mcu that is 100 happening sometime
in phase 6. now another one that's going
to be coming in phase 6 most likely is a
spider-man movie with tom holland
spider-man no way home started off the
multiverse in the mcu and essentially
secret wars is basically going to be
spider-man no way home but on a bigger
level incursions are going to happen
universes are going to start to collide
into each other and different variants
are going to meet each other and fight
side by side so we'll have again
multiple variants of spider-man multiple
variants of the scarlet witch the new
captain america heck we could even see
cameos from old actors like scarlett
johansson robert downing jr chris evans
they could come back and play variants
of themselves so secret wars is going to
be pretty insane but i am expecting a
spider-man movie especially since marvel
studios president kevin feige and amy
pascal of sony did confirm that they are
already working on a spider-man 4. now
there's a project that was not shown for
phase 5 that everybody thought was going
to be shown for phase 5 that everybody
is really curious about now and that is
armor wars armor wars is going to start
don cheadle he of course is going to be
playing war machine and the plot for
this series is supposedly what happens
when the iron man technology gets into
the wrong hands this kind of sounds like
something dr doom would do or be behind
at least now rumors are going crazy that
doctor doom is about to enter the mcu
this year and he does have connections
to she-hulk and he does of course have
connections to wakanda him probably
wanting vibranium so doom could
definitely be hinted at this year and if
he does come he could go on to become
god emperor doom in secret wars just
like he is in the comics but until then
when he's introduced to secret wars he
could get his hands on some iron man
technology and kind of start to try to
take over the world and that could be a
big plot for armor wars now another
project that is most likely going to be
in phase six because it just fits is a
nova movie now this was announced by
deadline they said that richard rider
aka nova is joining the marvel cinematic
universe as sources tell deadline marvel
is developing a nova project with moon
knight writer sabir perzada so since
they already have a writer for the movie
i'm assuming that it's coming in phase
six plus nova just makes sense to have
for the cosmic side of the mcu also not
to mention guardians of the galaxy vol 3
seems to be the end for a lot of the
guardians so nova could easily join the
new guardians of the galaxy so i am
expecting nova in phase six now here's
where we get a little bit into the
unknown we know that marvel's what if
season 2 is actually coming in phase 5
but kevin feige did not list it on phase
5. having said that we know that
spider-man freshman year and marvel
zombies are going to be coming out in
2024 which would technically make them
part of phase six so those could occupy
a couple of dates here that are listed
for phase six or they could be left out
of this much like what if season two was
left out of phase five again that's a
little bit unknown at the time but we do
know that those two projects are coming
in 2024 another one that we have is eros
and pip the troll eros aka star fox and
pip the troll were introduced in the
post credit scene for the eternals then
marvel studios confirmed an eternal
sequel then after this san diego
comic-con kevin feige said that we were
going to explore arrows and pip the
troll pretty soon and i'm assuming that
they're not going to get their own movie
but are going to be major characters in
eternals 2. so i'm guessing that the
second eternals film is going to be a
part of phase six especially if you
consider what secret wars actually is
the eternals are definitely going to
want to step in marvel studios has also
confirmed a shang chi sequel and that
could definitely take one of these
listed slots here for phase six
especially if you consider what the post
credits for shang chi were chiang chi
and katie basically became avengers they
were with wang and they were talking to
captain marvel and bruce banner then
captain marvel got some sort of a
distress signal and she had to go so the
setup was very clear and kevin feige
confirmed a sequel the only question is
will they have the sequel before secret
wars or will they just have xiang chi in
these team-up films and we'll get a
sequel after secret wars and the other
ones that could occupy these slots that
have been mentioned so far are the okoye
series coming to disney plus and we also
have some series that are going to be
focused on the world of wakanda that
might occupy these slots as well so the
future of phase 6 is extremely bright we
should expect deadpool the mutants nova
and a lot of other awesome characters
being introduced to the mcu but let me
know what you are most excited about
what you would love to see in the
comments down below and if you could
give the video a like and subscribe so
you don't miss out on any of the latest
marvel news for live updates you can
always follow me on instagram and
twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof